I thought it was a good speech uh well
delivered it was very good as well
because it was short sometimes these
speeches go on forever she set out the
themes but didn't try to delve into the
detail because I think that has to come
later but I think the most eye-catching
part of the speech which made sense
given the
let's be honest pretty awful two or
three days that we had had up there with
various people taking lumps out of each
other I think what was good about her
speech was as she got past that and then
we have uh the juxtaposition which is
perfect which is to say it's the
anti-growth Coalition that we are
against so it's growth versus
anti-growth now I have taught a couple
of Labor colleagues I know and they went
oh I'm not sure about that one
um and I think that's the point so now
you start to frame it so it makes it
more difficult for people to you know
take and take edge with it I suppose you
mentioned a difficult few days a pretty
awful few days with colleagues taking
lumps out of each other
extraordinary hasn't it discipline just
breaking down it has but I was pondering
it I mean I went on yesterday to tell
people just to calm down and just think
about what we're doing here but in fact
as I thought about it yesterday I
thought um
in a way this might be catharthic
because we'd been through a really tough
period this has been a terrible three
years no Governors faced three years
like this with kovid and then the
postcoded lockdown Nightmare of You Know
High inflation a war in Ukraine just
about everything you can think of for
three years has really caused problems
with the government and then we've had
the fall of Boris Johnson and then a
leadership election where the leader
comes who doesn't have a public mandate
because it's not a general election and
people are divided because different
people stood and lots of people
supported Rishi sunak not her so there's
a bit of Edge and bitterness and so I
thought to myself actually on reflection
that this may turn out to be quite
cathartic because the conservative party
I think in this conference stared over
the edge and I think they stepped back
uh today with her speech now all I hope
is that people recognize that there is
no other way but to get behind Liz truss
and and make it work for her and I think
this growth versus
the anti-growth Coalition is a very good
starting point for the conservative
party it could bring them together very
well you you say that people pulled over
the edge but then realize there's no
other way but to row in behind this
trust I have to say that that is quite
different to what some of your other
colleagues are saying at conference
after spending a few days there there's
already talk about changing the rules of
the 1922 committee so that there could
be another leadership contest of
potentially bypassing the members and
MPS deciding on a Unity candidate
because this is someone who they don't
believe can win an election that's going
on
yeah it's going on amongst a few of my
colleagues who you know sometimes need
to grow up and secondly need to figure
out what happens next so if they can't
get Unity now what are they going to
Unity candidate suddenly pop out of
nowhere and say it's all right everybody
we're together they have somebody that
the party voted for it's within the
rules they've got to get behind that
individual that happens to be Liz trust
the second bit about this is if you go
on changing your leaders and having into
Nissan Warfare I tell you what with the
polls the way they are now you might as
well head straight to the exit door
because that's exactly where we will go
and it will be very painful for many
people so it's very true I've seen this
time and time again in the time I've
been in politics is that there are to be
quite Frank with you some people who are
really intellectually challenged about
politics and who don't understand that
it's the electorate that puts us here
and if they lose trust in us and if they
think that we're incompetent because all
we do is fight each other this happened
to labor it's happened to us in the past
and they will not vote for us so what
right now that speech today was really
important because they have to get
behind this concept of us for growth and
those people what she called the
Coalition the anti-growth Coalition we
need to Now understand who the real
enemy is here it's those who are really
opposed to growth and those who actually
want growth and are prepared to take the
decisions are necessary if they can't
fit within that well all I can say to
them is they're on their way out you
have done of work in your time of
politics around poverty I just wonder if
you look at what's happened in the first
month or so of the Liz trust Premiership
trying to abolish the 45p rate of tax
not saying that benefits will be raised
in line with inflation
scrapping the cap on Bankers bonuses is
there a risk that the conservatives are
effectively playing into what some
people have always thought about the
conservatives that you care about rich
people and you don't care about poor
people well I set up the center for
social justice to try and help all
politicians but the conservatives
particularly to understand that it's
important to understand exactly how
difficult it is when you're on low
income because things cost more on low
income than they do for wealthier people
you know you get your bank statement
printed they charge you more for it you
know cash is how you live your life but
you try finding cash sometimes it's
really really difficult so all these
things cost a bit more so my point
really to them was to try and understand
that therefore we have to make sure they
have a flaw put under them so they can
move back into work and you want people
to move back into work there are five
million people outside of that and you
want them to go through so those are the
sort of changes you need and the reality
really for all of us is not to make
simplistic Solutions the answer to this
we want people to move back into work I
did the big reforms on Universal Credit
help people survive through the pandemic
it's there to be used it's very good
about getting people back to work and we
need to make sure that we understand
that nature and the one if I have a
criticism at all uh this phrase uh the
growth those in favor of growth both of
the anti-growth coalition
that actually should have started two or
three weeks ago because the argument
right now that we should be making is
those who are in favor of growth what
growth does for those on the lowest
incomes lifts their incomes gives them
more jobs gives them more opportunity
it's not about wealthier people
particularly it's about people on low
incomes of growth we should have made
that argument all the way through then
talked about tax and be very careful
about then how you juxtapose that so the
45p tax rate was uh when set against
benefit Cuts is just
stupid and therefore that both needs to
be cleared out the way Liz has done one
and I think they'll clear the other out
of the way too and just to be clear by
clearing the other out the way you're
saying that benefits should effectively
rise in line with inflation Yes again I
have to keep getting my colleagues and
others this is looking backwards okay so
the last rise was below inflation at the
time it Rose because it was based on the
previous six months where inflation
wasn't as high so actually already
benefits would come in under inflation
at the next one in a way it'll be
setting resetting the bar so that
they're stable my view on this is it's
it's the key to get into getting the
benefit bill down is to get people back
to work that was always what we designed
in Universal you think then they go
paying tax and then we become do you
think that let's try should come out now
and commit uh to saying that benefits
will go up in language I think the
government's going to have to say
something about this clearly I don't I
understand fully why she couldn't say
anything during the conference I have no
problem about that and therefore those
who are fighting to say say something or
not say something I think the truth is
she's not going to jump ahead of the
statement they're going to make on the
economy because it would be dark you
then start ruling out all sorts of stuff
and you never get anywhere but when
that's done I think they need to make it
clear that actually that's not the right
way to go because you want people to be
able to move swiftly up into work and if
you reduce that amount of benefit
they're getting which by the way isn't
that great then it makes it more
difficult to take the big jobs the big
choice about taking those jobs doing
part-time work moving up the scale so
and then a cost of living crisis with
inflation everything else bearing down
on them and as I said earlier on at the
lowest level of income the cost of
living is actually higher because things
are more expensive so we need to take
that into consideration as well it's not
the same yes there are lots of things to
be done in taxation I think particularly
the thresholds by the way which drags
senior teachers senior nurses in who are
not wealthy people that needs to be
looked at when we get to that but that's
my personal view but when you talk about
people on benefits we should recognize a
lot of them are beyond the world of work
and so you've got to be very careful how
you do this and I think for a party like
mine if you're talking about growth
talking about tax cutting you can make
sure the message is well-rounded and you
understand the problems that exist for
those down at the lower incomes